Qin Shi Huang leads the Chinese civ in
sid meier's civilization 6 Qin Shi Huang
United the warring States of China and
became the first emperor of the Qin
Dynasty his economic and political
reforms brought standardization and
central rule to China and he built the
famous Terracotta Army China's special
civ ability is called dynastic cycles
they get a larger boost from Eureka's
and inspirations compared to other sibs
chin is a ruler who gets things done his
builders receive an additional use and
he can use builders to boost
construction on ancient and classical
wonders the Chinese unique unit is the
Crouching Tiger cannon this high power
short-range unit doesn't require
specific resources to produce the Great
Wall has returned in Civilization six
but now it is a unique tile improvement
for the Chinese at the start of the game
it will provide defense and gold and as
you advance through time it'll give you
bonus culture and tourism keep in mind
that because it's a tile improvement
you'll have to keep dedicating builders
to the task of expanding it just like in
history like Egypt China is a wonderful
sieve in the early game but unlike Egypt
China can be much more defensive and
insular the Great Wall will be a
formidable barrier to protect you in the
early game how will you roll the Middle
Kingdom in sid meier's civilization 6
you